the exact problem of plastic inertial is
this
now you come to the plastic graveyard
here the Doge
the washed up remains of a throwaway
society
now you see the enormity of the problem
this isn't litter that's been dropped on
the beach it's come in from the sea
recklessly thrown away distributed in
the currents and then swept ashore this
is the most injured as the blue one
it's a single-use plastic and this if it
gets down you had it this is all in the
model this is from the model
keep something shopping-mall this is so
prevalent in Finland shopping line
afros inspired the world's biggest ever
beach clean once a week volunteers clear
what they can knowing full well that the
next tide will lay a new carpet of
plastic the ocean throws it up ocean
pukes out every two months three months
you know and if you don't clean it it
will get piled on piled on piled on it's
just not convenient for the fishes and
the marine creatures and marina birds
you know it's their house it's it's
there where they belong they live they
survive they're crying for justice
because we have messed up to their
houses worldwide the equivalent of one
rubbish truck of plastic waste is being
dumped into the ocean every minute by
2050 the trash in the sea is likely to
weigh more than all of the fish this is
the debris of modern life almost all of
it single-use plastic a bag used for a
few minutes to take the shopping home a
straw used for seconds to drink some
juice and thrown away with little regard
for what happened to it and now being
brought back in on the tide marine
litter is a worldwide problem this is
the River Thames once the plastic
reaches the North Sea it'll begin to
break down into tiny fragments over many
decades but it never completely
disappears the tiny pieces are called
micro plastic it's eaten by sea
creatures and ends up in our food this
portion of Marcus's contains about
ninety particles of plastic
this scientist carried out the first
comprehensive risk assessment shown
exclusively to Sky News which suggests
that the micro plastic can be absorbed
into our bloodstream his research shows
that by the end of the century as many
as four
tiny fragments a year could build up in
the body I've asked many physicians
colleagues professors and and so on
what does microplastic what could micro
plastic do when it gets into our blood
system and the blunt answer was we don't
know so we don't know but in principle
they could accumulate what I think they
could do what was suggested by
physicians is that perhaps they could
accumulator on joints or certain types
of tissue and cause inflammation there
the plastic is already proving fatal for
some marine creatures this bird has died
slowly it's there's no fat remaining
these are full MERS that have been found
dead on the beach the post-mortem on the
stomach isn't for the squeamish there's
quite a bit of stuff in here I'm not
sure what it is but you'll see so you
can see this a lot of plastic in here
goodness me
and it's so fun of that yeah so this
gives it is basically full of purses
with so much plastic blocking it system
the bird wouldn't have felt hungry and
probably starved to death it's suffering
from our mistakes and it's it's a
disgrace for mankind I think too that
you find this in animals cleaned and
carefully laid out this is the inventory
of the birds gizzard 18 pieces of
plastic weighing half a gram scaled up
to a human that's a lunchbox of trash I
will not like my son to have this in his
thumb our waste recklessly disposed of
is in the ocean food chain and it's
coming back to haunt us Thomas More Sky
News